good morning believe nation today's
message is don't complain over to you
manny pacquiao how do you think that
impacted you growing up not having your
data room actually I'm not blaming my
dad it's a it's good for us that our dad
is not around because we're not relying
our dad we will learn how to work hard
because we're old boy so we learn how to
work hard and to make money and you know
in a nice way and that's how we how we
get strong people who complain they lose
at life they lose at life look at the
people who complain the most around you
look at your friends look at your friend
lives and people in your circle you want
to do some nonstop complainers you know
who those people are chances are they
are the least successful people in your
network people who complain don't rise
up it doesn't happen you look at the top
people and any field they take action on
complaints they make money off of
complainers they build businesses around
complainers entrepreneurs see a problem
and what do we do what do we do we solve
it that's what entrepreneurs do well
other people are too busy complaining
about their problems entrepreneurs see
that and say hey hmm this problem kind
of sucks and other people are probably
going through the same thing the more
people have that problem the bigger the
opportunity is for you I look at my own
stories and example in my very first
business the founders started the
company I joined later as an owner
because he had a problem in his
laboratory and he wanted software to
help him victus it was designed around
his own need I looked at my youtube
channel you guys are well aware of since
you're watching this video I didn't want
to make these videos I didn't want to
have to do this
I wanted to consume content from famous
entrepreneurs I wanted to be around
successful people because I felt like
the people around me weren't having the
kind of success that I wanted and so I
wanted to surround myself with this
daily and there wasn't really good
content on YouTube there's tons of
videos on YouTube but not the content
that I wanted I could sit through 10
hours of an Elon Musk
you know interview series to get like a
couple of good points so I wanted to be
easier and instead of complaining that
this didn't exist I decided to make it I
made it and I shared it and it was great
for me and hopefully it's great for you
you guys are enjoying the content and
learning getting inspired as well I just
wanted to be a consumer I wished a
problem didn't exist I wish I could just
go turn on my computer and boom there's
amazing content for me to consume and
enjoy and uplift myself and learn
something from but it didn't exist and
so I made it and so the next time you
catch yourself either complaining
yourself stop it okay
stop it stop complaining look for a
solution look for an opportunity because
that may become a business thing for you
and if you are hanging around people who
are just complaining complaining
complaining and complaining don't let
them bring you down don't let their
negativity bring you down you are a
product of your environment and if
you're hanging around positive uplifting
insightful thoughtful things people
videos that's what you will become and
if you're hanging around negative
complaining whining individuals that's
what you're going to become so choose
wisely and stop complaining so the
question today today is I'm curious what
was one complaint that you turn into an
opportunity for yourself leave it down
the comments below I'm super curious to
see what you guys have to say I also
want to give a quick chatter to Terrance
Robertson fall thank you so much
Terrance for picking up a copy of my
book your one-word and really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the reason so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events better
oh wait
give me I'm a pretty happy guy yeah you
know I think that's one of the keys to
success I read an article that the
difference between successful people and
people that struggle are successful
people exude joy Jeff if you're not a
happy guy and other people don't want to
hang out right why would they hang out
with right if you're miserable and
nobody wants to spend time with you
how are you ever going to get ahead yeah
it like complain I remember when we were
really young this lesson was taught to
me by my dad and I kind of had a
miserable day at school because you know
the kids make fun of you you're an
immigrant you're poor and I came home
and I was feeling sorry for myself and
my dad came home it's going to sound so
melodramatic he walked a couple miles to
the factory I was a blue-collar guy and
I came home and just stood there and I
was complaining about my day where were
you living we were living in like a oh
this stage would be three times the size
and a little apartment here is him oh my
gosh oh it wasn't it wasn't Pleasant and
my dad was just and and I was
complaining and feeling sorry for myself
that my dad looks at me and says never
complain you should always be happy with
the opportunities given you and that was
it and so you you know you can feel that
pain how many of you have ever
complained in your life
yeah you know here's what I've learned
about complaining in order to complain I
have to have a reference point of
something better that I want that I'm
not willing to risk creating now let me
explain that again I have to have a
reference point in my mind of something
I want it's better than what I have that
I'm not willing to risk creating so what
I do is complain about it instead see if
I was complaining about my wife it would
mean that I would have to believe that
somewhere out there in the world there's
a better woman than my wife see if every
woman on the planet died except my wife
do you think I'd go to work the next day
and complain about it no she's the only
one and I'd be gone hey and I got her
this is really cool right do you ever
hear anyone complain about gravity very
rarely you know gravity makes us all
bend over do you ever see an old person
walking down a street going gravity they
have a little Walker
I hate gravity don't work for gravity I
wouldn't be all bent over like this
gravity sucks
now have you ever heard an older person
doing it no the reason they don't
complain about gravity is because
there's no alternative to it you know
gravity just is so if someone's
complaining about something it means
they know there's something they can do
about it because we don't complain about
the things we can't change so as soon as
you hear yourself complaining I want you
to stop and say okay what would I rather
have remember Law of Attraction always
focus on what you want not what you
don't want because when you're talking
about what you don't want when you're
complaining and blaming you're focusing
on that which you don't want and you're
accelerating its expression out into the
universe with those negative feelings
and yet we'll spend a majority of our
time complaining about so many things
and usually we complain about them to
people who can't do anything about it
another thing you can do is never ever
complain when I see people complaining
I'm just like what are you what are you
doing like your life is so short are you
really going to say you're complaining
let me put this in perspective okay I'm
34 okay I'm 34 now in my 20s I didn't
know that many people that died okay as
you start to hit 30 people start to die
okay I had a friend that died last week
okay people are just going to start
dying
okay I've also almost died myself a
couple times who here in this room has
almost died before put your hands up
look at that look at that crowd now if
that many people have almost died let me
be a little more before you get here how
many people here weren't here to put
their hands up just probably little go
something but I actually didn't die like
right in the crowd right now that is
going to be you okay you are going to be
dead soon enough so don't waste your
time complaining okay don't waste your
time complaining is the terrible
terrible idea all right so basically
what you want to do is like never come
never be negative never complained